so justin trudeau ended democracy in
canada he declared martial law this week
the irony is he seems to be losing
control of canada
thank god
and he's becoming more desperate by the
day
just today a conservative member of
parliament challenged trudeau in his
declaration of martial law in the
country and in response trudeau accused
her of standing with nazis
conservative party members can stand
with people who wave swastikas they can
stand with people who wait
[Applause]
so we don't know the member of
parliament he was talking to we believe
she's jewish though probably not a nazi
sympathizer
meanwhile justin trudeau's government
has been carrying out their threat to
seize the bank accounts and
cryptocurrency wallets of anyone who
criticizes justin trudeau yeah just a
democracy by the way our state
department has said nothing about this
as democracy ends and tyranny reigns in
our closest ally in the world joe
biden's state department has said not
one word
because hungary's dangerous
man they're dishonest canada's
government
government
just banned 34 crypto wallets tied to
the freedom convoy
trudeau's allies the media of course
have been very busy helping him they've
been harassing anyone who dared to
donate to the truckers today the
washington post owned by the world's
richest man began contacting people who
donated as little as forty dollars to
the convoy
can you imagine that's not journalism
it's an incitement to violence among
other things
then a reporter at the ottawa citizen
called ellison ma exposing the identity
of a cafe owner who dared to donate 250
bucks to the convoy now that owner is
receiving threats and she had to close
her business this afternoon ilhan omar
to her credit tweeted this quote i
failed to see why any journalist felt
the need to report on a shop owner
making such an insignificant donation
than to get them harassed it's
unconscionable and journalists need to
do better
so elon omar is generally pretty
loathsome but when she says something
that is true
we're going to give her credit for it
because unlike the las vegas sun we're
not liars
victor davis hansen is a senior fellow
at the hoover institution he joins us
tonight professor thanks so much for
coming on so the washington post
cheering on and making possible the
harassment of small dollar donors
to a truck driver convoy what do you
make of this
i i think they're inadvertently doing
their best to sort of make a tenement
square scene where they're in the tank
and the truckers are the citizen that
says come on
and i don't think they intended to make
this a fault line or to be iconic but
what's happened tucker is that the
truckers have been
iconic of this fault line throughout the
middle of north america and on one side
you have these people who
are muscular and they brave the weather
and they're out there with covid and
they're bringing our food and our
building materials and our fuel and
they're opposed on the other hand by the
zoom class who's profited enormously
pretty much in safety due to these
truckers and people like them and yet
the truckers tend to have the pragmatic
because they're in the real world they
have to deal with real things and they
have greater common sense so they look
at omicron and they say this natural
virus is in its descendants it's more
infectious but it's not as lethal so
people are getting hurt immunity it's on
the wane it's time to let up and after
all we're in our trucks by ourselves and
they give all these practical
reasons why you should listen to them
and the government has no answer and yet
they're the government of knowledge and
the
the intellect the intellect and they
can't answer them and then the truckers
are also saying you know this fault
line's more about more than us it's
about the fundamental principle of
western jurisprudence and that's a
symmetrical application of the law and
when there was
protest all through north america canada
two blm antifa they had no mass they
even went or health care professionals
over a thousand said that blm didn't
have to wear a mask out in the front and
and so everybody understands if that the
trudeau government was for the blm and
antifa and they were against people like
this and they had no rational systematic
fairness and that truckers are bringing
that up and ultimately i don't think
trudeau is going to win this even the
optics are bad that he has a pajama boy
persona and these people are wonderful
people they're practical people and
they're empathetic and i think
eventually
they're going to trudeau is going to
lose and it's really a referendum on
this ongoing cultural struggle that
we're having in this country against an
entrenched bureaucratic elite and the
corporations silicon valley the media
versus the average person that has
nothing other than common sense and
popular support that's exactly right
he's a monster and a dictator i think
all normal people are rooting against
him fervently
professor thank you so much for that